NARRATOR: In 1995, Tony Hawk
wins gold in the first X Games
and goes on to
dominate the decade.
In 1999 he cranks it up a notch,
attempting a never
before done trick, the 900.
HAWK: A 900 is
a two and a half spin rotation
sort of summersault in the air,
holding onto your skateboard.
The thing that makes it
the most challenging is that
you are blind to
your landing zone twice.
DUNCAN (over speaker):
Yeah, 900!
HAWK: I had no plans
of doing 900 at X Games.
I think it was
the onsite announcer,
Dave Duncan that said,
"Oh let's see that 900,"
'cause he knew
I'd been trying it.
DUNCAN (over speaker): Run back,
Tony's got a shot at it.
Can he do it?
HAWK: And so I just
started trying it more
to appease the crowd and to
appease Dave on the mic, like,
here's what it looks like.
DUNCAN (over speaker):
900! 900, this could be it.
Oh. The closest one.
(cheering)
We're not worthy.
SEMIAO: When he'd go up and
start flipping it was like...
(gasps).
(sighs).
HAWK: Something
inside me just said,
"You're either making this or
they're gonna cart you off of
the ramp to the hospital,"
those were the only two
endings to that night for me.
DUNCAN (over speaker):
Tony, Tony, Tony, Tony, Tony,
history in the making.
SEMIAO: The 900 was
revolutionary 'cause
it had never been done before.
My heart was in mouth.
I didn't want him to be
taken away in an ambulance,
I wanted him to land it.
HAWK: At one point I
thought it wasn't possible
and it was just like,
I wasn't gonna give up.
(cheering)
SEMIAO: And when he
did it, that pure shock.
HAWK: When I made it, I saw all
my peers rushing towards me and
it was like that,
that made it real.
SEMIAO: And that's how
you achieve legendary status.
It was big for the X Games,
it was big for Tony Hawk,
it was big for skateboarding,
like today we'd say,
"It went viral," you know, and,
and that was, was
really a seminal moment.
(cheering)
DUNCAN (over speaker):
What you got to say?
How do you feel right now?
HAWK (over speaker): If
it weren't for you people,
I would have never
made that, I swear to God.
(cheering)